in indien geht ihnen die kraft ja
buchstäblich die luft aus und europa
schaut zu und spricht das war ein sehr
wichtiger historischer moment für uns
dass wir sichergestellt haben dass die
europäische union eng an der seite
indien steht
warme worte aus dem westen während in
indien öffentliche plätze zu
massengräbern und krematorien werden
da wird jetzt mit hochdruck daran
gearbeitet inwieweit gesorgt doch
produzierenden anlagen dort hinbringen
können ganz europa macht das seit einem
halben jahr schon fordert indien mit
mehr als 100 weiteren ländern den
patentschutz für die impfstoffe
vorübergehend aufzuheben um weltweit
schneller produzieren zu können
doch auch beim digital gipfel mit der eu
am vergangenen wochenende kein
durchbruch für indiens regierungschef
modi auf den hilferuf nach freigabe der
patente antwortet die bundesregierung
mit einer absage und schickt stattdessen
spenden darunter gut 100 beatmungsgeräte
für ein land mit fast eineinhalb
milliarden menschen
was jetzt passiert mit den spenden
basierten aktivitäten funktioniert
eigentlich wie moderner ablasshandel
man hat versäumt rechtliche
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen die macht
der pharmaindustrie im öffentlichen
interesse zu begrenzen
und jetzt muss man mit hilfeleistungen
um die ecke kommen unterdessen nimmt die
impfkampagne in deutschland und vielen
reichen ländern immer mehr an fahrt auf
der westen hat sich eingedeckt so hat
kanada für jeden seiner bürger fast 10
ein halb impfdosen bestellt
großbritannien pro kopf gut 8
die europäische union orderte für jeden
einwohner mehr als viereinhalb impfungen
für andere wird es da in thailand hat
für jeden bürger gerade noch eine dose
ein inder muss rein rechnerisch sei eine
impfung mit sechs anderen teilen
das war ein deutliches signal an die
armen länder dass ihre leben weniger
zählen als die lennon als die leben in
den reichen ländern
das was da passiert ist seit dem tag als
die pandemie 20 20 ausgebrochen ist ist
ein politisches scheitern ist ein
moralisches scheitern von der moral zur
medizin
solange das virus in ländern wie indien
weiter mutieren kann weil menschen
ungeimpft sind ist europas sicherheit
trügerisch unklar ob die impfstoffe vor
neuen mutanten schützen das wissen alle
doch es bleibt bei appellen eine globale
pandemie verlangt gemeinsames
internationales handeln und
wechselseitige unterstützung ja wie ich
habe mehrfach dazu aufgerufen dass der
cobit 19 impfstoffen öffentliches gut
sein muss überall für jeden zugänglich
die pandemie wird erst dann unter
kontrolle sein wenn sie in allen teilen
der welt und der kontrolle ist weil den
worten an die welt so wenig vakzine
folgen werden die stimmen lauter die
eine aufhebung des patentschutzes
fordern vergangene woche stimmt auch joe
biden in den chor mit 1 ausgerechnet der
präsident des landes das bisher
überhaupt keine impfstoffe aus dem land
ließ aus dem weißen haus heißt es jetzt
auf einmal
die us-regierung steht fest zum schutz
von geistigem eigentum
doch sie unterstützt dem sinn einer
schnellen beendigung der pandemie die
forderung nach einer aussetzung des
patentschutzes für kobelt 19 impfungen
moralische kehrtwende oder weltmacht
strategie die motivation der der beiden
administration ist relativ klar und auch
offengelegt kein geheimnis die beiden
minister einen führungsanspruch eine art
leadership in globaler gesundheits
speziell denn auch russland und china
nutzen den impfstoff für größeren
einfluss auf der welt mit den paletten
kommt erst die hilfe dann die
abhängigkeit ein modell dass die usa
ihren rivalen nicht überlassen wollen
wir sehen dass russland und china schon
jetzt vorpreschen und europa muss hier
aufpassen sich nicht ins abseits zu
schießen
denn die wahrnehmung in der welt ist
nicht das europa hilft sondern die
wahrnehmung ist eher dass europa bremst
und das ist letztlich auch geopolitisch
katastrophal für deutschland
washingtons kurswechsel bringt die
bundesregierung und ihren schutz der
pharmakonzerne in erklärungsnot sind die
gewinne der pharmakonzerne
schützenswerte als menschen leben in
indien das hauptthema ist nicht die
frage von patenten das hauptthema ist
die frage von produktionskapazitäten und
gerade ma eben stoffe zu produzieren ist
nichts was man mal eben per lizenz dann
irgendwo in irgend einer fabrik
irgendwie machen kann indien und
südafrika sagen sie haben die
produktionskapazitäten ihren diese also
es gibt ja es gibt tatsächlich
produktionen in kooperation in beiden
ländern
gleichzeitig möchte ich aber auch
sicherstellen dass mit innovationen und
entwicklungen die es in der europäischen
union gibt wir auch verantwortlich
umgehen
im klartext sparen will auf freiwillige
kooperation setzen die konzerne aber
nicht so freigabe zwingen die
unternehmen die jetzt im stoffe haben
haben sich dumm und dusselig verdient
sie haben riesige erträge gemacht ist es
richtig dass patente geschützt werden
denn nur so können unternehmen anreize
haben auch in der zukunft in forschung
entwicklung zu investieren
aber man muss eben auch berücksichtigen
dass viele der unternehmen die diese
impfstoffe entwickelt haben das ohne
staatliche hilfen gar nicht gekonnt
hätten
in der tat wurde die entwicklung der
kogit impfstoffe weltweit staatlich mit
circa 90 milliarden euro gefördert
für die pharmakonzerne eine lukrative
unterstützung
seit die whu corona zur pandemie im märz
2020 erklärte stieg der aktienkurs des
pharmariesen astrazeneca um 23 prozent
die aktie des deutschen unternehmens
biontech stieg sogar bis mitte
vergangener woche um 500 prozent
der us-konzern moderner konnte an der
us-börse nasdaq um 630 prozent zulegen
moderner dessen eigenanteil an der
entwicklung des impfstoffes nach bbc-
recherchen bei null lag
wann wenn nicht jetzt wann hätten wir
ein anrecht darauf wenn nicht jetzt wann
müsste moderner ein zwei drei schritte
zurück treten und sagen wir können gar
kein anrecht mehr auf dieses patent
haben weil wir befinden uns in einer
globalen ausnahme situation weil er
öffentlich gestellt wurden
seit sechs monaten sind cupid 19
impfstoffe auf dem markt sie haben
konzernen milliarden beschert und sie
haben menschenleben gerettet
weniger in indien als in anderen in
reicheren teilen der welt
[Musik]